Regarding the black sand blood root capsules in an effort to clear the breast cancer that has possibly spread is it okay or safe to increase the dosage and take more than three a day.
So the black sand blood root capsules somebody has a question about that last week or the week before too.
And I said that I wish they would have deemed it something different because it isn't black sand but it doesn't blood root in it.
It has gravity only in it. It has burdock in it and it has chaperonell in it. These are all four very positively known herbs for helping kill cancer.
Can you take more than three a day? Yes, could you over dose on this? Well, you could over dose on anything but you know you could I mean a person could take probably up to 12 a day probably take way more than that.
You're still not at any sort of a half of the lethal dose or anything like that. I don't know if there is a lethal dose of these herbs, but you couldn't give you a tummy ache or something maybe.
So yes, you could increase the dose of that if you feel like God has leading you to it. I think there's I think that there's just a mixture of those four herbs in it.
You compare that with like other like like oxy. So oxy is another known cancer killer. It also has burdock. It has some different mix like red clover and oregano grape, which is burberry.
And licorice, which is mainly used to help heal the God. And then you compare that to like seac. So what herb seac is another blended product. It's a blended herb that has burdock root. It has a sheep soil in it and slippery elm, which is typically slippery elm is used just to help heal the God.
It has Indian rhubarb. So you notice some similarities in these different herbs.
I think I shared a couple of questions a few weeks ago about burdock root burdock rose. I mean, I got enough burdock growing in my yard to probably help every cancer person patients on the planet if they let it take burdock.
It is a great herb for cancer. That's a common herb in all three of those formulas. So yes, you could take more.